this week marks the first anniversary of
Donald Trump's election to the
presidency CBS News chief Washington
correspondent Face the Nation anchor
John Dickerson met some of the
president's supporters in New Hampshire
he talked with them about mr. Trump's
performance a group of three men and
three women range in ages from 26 to 82
years old they all voted for mr. Trump
last November to identify as Republicans
while the others say their independence
they spoke with John at the foundry
restaurant in Manchester about the
changes the president has made in the
country and their community it's been
one year since the aisle Trump is
elected president who here by show of
hands thinks the country is doing better
now than it was a year ago all six of
you all right Peter what what makes you
think the country is better off after a
year of Donald Trump as president well
the economy is certainly a big thing it
was nice to see the economy jump a
little bit from the end of Obama's
presidency it seems like a lot of that
is just coming from promises that Trump
is making like he's saying I'm going to
make things better for business I'm
going to lower corporate tax rates so
that builds enthusiasm so companies seem
like they're more willing to invest in
the future I agree with everything that
that Peters just said I think that the
word fiscally we're doing better
financially the stock market's going up
but I also think that it's because a lot
of things that haven't been put into
place yet like the tax reform Terry what
do you feel about people who are in
Congress should they work for their
constituents or work for Donald Trump if
they're if they're Republicans they
ought to follow their party platform and
from whatever stems from that we have a
majority or the GOP has a majority in
Congress
and the presidency and they're not
working together and it's shameful do
you think President Trump has helped
foster a sense of community in America
or oh he's made it much worse in the
past presidents have brought nations
together why is President Trump why
can't he do that
like he just well lie or like make
things up for the effect it has on other
people that's not a way that a good
person will live their life does the
president tell the truth and if he
doesn't does that bother you it does
bother and it is very frustrating it's
one of the big knocks on the president
is if he can't seem to keep his ego in
check and keep the lies in to control he
needs to act presidential and step it up
you voted for him is your vote up in the
air now absolutely
absolutely John Dickerson is with us now
this is fascinating how would you sum up
where they are well they are behind the
president in a way that I've not seen in
politics it's not just he's our guy but
the message the president is sending out
there about the economy about what he's
done in office on regulations they have
internalized they have some complaints
about him but they it's not just
boosterism it's actual belief in what he
is promoting specifically with respect
to things like tax cuts where they have
heard what he's saying and can repeat it
and are therefore it makes their support
more durable as they hear criticisms
from elites from the press from
Democrats even from other Republicans is
there a difference between those who
support Trump because of style and
culture because of the finger of the
establishment and those who find that
the policies that he talks about tax
reform how he feels about immigrants and
and other issues of those that they
fervently feel passion about there's a
connection they had that first gut level
connection with him basically he's our
guy he's going to punch the
establishment in the nose but then when
you ask them about policy about the
economy about what he's done well what
they think about Congress they've
connected to what he's saying at a
policy level you may do there may be
debate about the specific policy views
they hold but they are not just making
that cultural connection and then
dropping it there they're still with him
as he makes the case for various pieces
of policy I like Charlie's word there
this group is fascinating because you
said that you you see supporters saying
yeah he lies he makes things up he needs
to be more presidential yet he's still
our guy on the other hand you have the
approval rating he has the lowest
approval rating of any president at any
time how do you explain the difference
between how a gas is core group of
people who support Donald Trump in
others who say look he's doing a bad job
well it's big and important in the
controlling party in the party that
controls Congress in the White House
right now so in the country and this is
the tension Republicans are fighting
with we saw this week in the election is
they have a party in which the president
has a very strong relationship with his
core and that core has a very low
opinion about Congress and they are the
ones who vote in off your elections and
so they're gonna matter in the elections
of 2018 so people in the Republican
Party can't distance themselves from
this core on the other hand this Court
does not represent the entire country
and in fact the behavior of the
president that excites some of his core
supporters has also we saw this week in
Virginia excited the other team and kept
them not only turning on on Election Day
but getting people to run for office and
that's the tension in the Republican
Party right now but when you talk to
these voters particularly if you're in
Congress you have to worry you can't
underestimate how happy they are with
the economy though oh my gosh they're
all very happy even if they say it
doesn't directly affect them they love
the fact that the markets doing well
thank you John Davis you can see more of
the focus group Sunday morning on Face
the Nation plus John speaks with
independent Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders and Republican senator Tim Scott
of South Carolina that's Sunday on CBS